y la aorta es la arteria más larga en su
cuerpo su corazón bombea sangre con
oxígeno fresco a su aorta para enviar el
oxígeno y los nutrientes a todos los
órganos y tejidos
su aorta está dividida en dos secciones
principales la aorta torácica y la aorta
abdominal la aorta torácica tiene cuatro
partes la raíz aórtica la aorta
ascendente arco aórtico y la aorta
descendente
a la pared de su aorta está compuesta
por tres capas que la hacen resistente
la capa interna o íntima la capa media
y la capa externa o adventicia
y la capa media muscular elástica
previene que su presión arterial rompa
la pared
con el paso del tiempo las enfermedades
degenerativas pueden causar que se rompa
la capa media debilitando así la pared
de su aorta el bombeo de la sangre
contra el área debilitada puede hacer
que sobresalga como un globo
cuando esta condición ocurre en su pecho
se le llama aneurisma de aorta torácica
estos aneurismas pueden ocurrir en uno
de varios lugares incluyendo la raíz
aórtica
la aorta ascendente
o la aorta descendente
la mayoría de los aneurismas torácico no
tienen síntomas sin embargo cuando
llegan a grandes tamaños pueden aparecer
varios síntomas dependiendo de la
gravedad y la ubicación del aneurisma
los síntomas de los aneurismas torácicos
estables pueden incluir falta de aire
dolor de pecho abdominal o de espalda
dificultad al tragar y ronquera
si el aneurisma se rompe o se disecciona
aparecerán síntomas más dramáticos
incluyendo sensación de desgarro en el
pecho dolor intenso en la espalda entre
los omóplatos mareos y dificultad al
caminar y hablar si tiene estos síntomas
debe buscar inmediatamente atención
médica ya que esta condición es
potencialmente mortal
y el bombeo de la sangre contra las
paredes aórticas débiles pueden llegar a
ser otra condición potencialmente mortal
llamada disección aórtica la cual puede
o no puede ocurrir dentro de una
aneurisma la mayoría de las disecciones
aórticas comunes empiezan con el daño de
la capa interna o íntima la sangre
avanza a través de la ruptura de la
íntima separando la de la media causando
sangrado dentro de la pared de su aorta
como resultado un colgajo llamado
excepto se forma entre el verdadero
canal aórtico y el canal falso desde
aquí la sangre puede atravesar la capa
exterior de la pared aórtica causando
una condición potencialmente mortal
inmediata o puede reingresar la aorta a
través de otro desgarro en la íntima con
el paso del tiempo los coágulos de
sangre pueden formarse en el canal falso
y una disección aórtica puede ser
clasificada de acuerdo a su ubicación y
la duración de los síntomas
en el sistema de stanford si usted tiene
una disección aórtica en su aorta
ascendente se les llama disección tipo
ad a todas las otras direcciones se les
llama tipo b
el síntoma más común de la disección de
aorta torácica es un dolor agudo o
punzante en el pecho normalmente es
repentino y grave si tiene una disección
tipo a usted está más propenso a sentir
dolor en su pecho si tiene una disección
tipo ve usted está más propenso a sentir
dolor en su espalda que en su pecho si
tiene estos síntomas debe buscar
atención médica inmediatamente ya que
esta condición puede ser potencialmente
mortal